hey guys today I'm going to talk about
the changes that Jon Snow experienced
after betrayal from his own man
after his death and resurrection about
the changes that most of fans didn't
even recognize firstly I'm going to talk
for a few moments about the reasons
because the wait showrunners had to kill
Jon Rippon I'm going to talk about the
changes that chance that brought to him
when only doubt the finishing blow to
John in the season 5 finale
it was the most upset scene since the
red wedding we've had our hero we've had
Jon Snow and all of the sudden he had
been killed our anger towards David and
then has never been as high as in that
very moment our hero was laying down on
the ground of Castle black as his eyes
were lifeless we told Vaughn from his
doors Oh at the screen faded to black
ironical fact that sir Alliser thorne
orchestrated John's death demanded
ending on the wall because he fought for
John's true father fought on House
Targaryen side during Robert's rebellion
fault for Rhaegar Targaryen but Jon Oh
surprisingly brought back to life after
only a few episodes which raised a few
important questions such as why did he
even die and what its purpose why it had
to happen in order to provide what few
sources such as media share the readers
and Watchers that John's dad was /
showrunners to focus on Jon in order to
forget about their as media said
mistakes about the whole Dorne story
media also try to solve this question
that statements that showrunner skill
Jon to push all negativity about their
writing aside along with the statement
that season 5 finale with a cliffhanger
of Jon's death also brought more Fame to
them it's possible that the media is
right the children's brought Jon's that
in order to distract viewers from
criticism and in order to bring more
publicity but while it might be possible
I definitely don't agree that then base
and David Benioff
wrote Jon that only to avoid criticism
in my opinion Jon's death was written to
cite him as the king in the north
it's very simple Jon didn't die he
wouldn't have last ball no matter of the
north and venture file being rolled by
Bolton's
no matter of senses pain and a matter of
freakin being Ramsay's prisoner
Jon wouldn't have let the ball as he
didn't
and his father aka uncle was killed and
while his brother
aka cousin marched south now that I
brought to you my opinion on the
importance of John's death the reason of
why showrunners had to write it let's
move on the changes that this st. that
brought to John Snow
he didn't change on as it changed beric
Dondarrion who didn't recover from any
of his deaths is being resurrected the
darién lost large pieces of his memory
each time or as Catelyn Stark that is
resurrected by Lord and Arian in the
books and appears as Lady Stoneheart
with her appearance being altered with
her flash becoming soft and looks more
like a zombie than a human being so
don't worry that didn't change on the
way as a change lords and Aryan and
Catelyn Stark John story and last season
was about his death not about to that of
his body by the death of his spirit his
hopes and his beliefs which is much more
meaningful John his whole life has been
doing things the best he could following
the justice and honor but still his own
goodness getting killed by his own
people at Castle black John's death
lasted only a few episodes but the
following episodes were of a huge
importance since at the moment of Jon's
resurrection until the season 6 finale
John was afraid but not because of the
dad he was afraid of a fact that he
can't control his own destiny John did
what he considered as the best choice
and those same choices got him killed he
was dead and brought back to life in
short amount of time whereupon he was
confused and afraid John was confused
because of fact that some kind of a
superior force some kind of God brought
him back to life but on the other hand
he experienced from the first place that
there is nothing after that
as he applies himself on meal Sanjay's
question when she asks him where did he
go and what did he see after the death
with nothing nothing at all John because
of this was confused since he is aware
that something else exists but at the
same time there was nothing after death
accompanied with a fear of not being
able to control his own destiny is a big
exchange that John experienced that are
being brought back to life he
Sherrington an actor to play Jon Snow
said that the line in which Melisandre
asked him about the life after death
about what did he see only John replies
that
nothing was brilliant to him as kid
considers that it cuts right into the
deepest fear that there is nothing after
death
align that Harrington considers as the
most important wine in the whole season
well the Battle of the bastards
definitely was a heroic story of a small
mountain man helping to their leader
helping Jon Snow to retake the
Winterfell to take control of the north
it also was a story about Jon's
personality that changed upon betrayal
of his own man this battle wouldn't even
have happened if John hadn't been killed
or if Sansa didn't say that she'll take
Winterfell their home with or without
his help as his first response as a
request regained Winterfell from
Bolton's walls and clothing I'm tired of
fighting it's all a done since I left
home I Falls and I lost even upon
realizing that there is not any other
way upon realizing that he has to retake
the Winterfell at least to try it John
was still afraid not afraid of a fact
that he and his makeshift army were
greatly outnumbered not a fact that he
might die but our fact that he might be
resurrected again as we could see in one
scene that took place on the night
before the battle as Vixia seen me Jon
Snow came to know Sandra and said if I
die don't bring me back keep Harrington
stated that John has never been afraid
of that
which in his opinion made John strong an
honorable person but Harrington also
said that John doesn't want to die again
not to mention to be revived again now
we're coming to the few most important
scenes that happen in John's story in
the last season foreseen that those of
the greatest meaning was a scene in
which Jon Snow failed to protect his own
little brother a scene in which recon
was killed in front of him a scene that
changed the whole battle while a huge
amount of us fans are believing that
upon recon that John charged in order to
align the oncoming arrows or even to
kill Ramsay I'm not of the same opinion
since John could have gone easily back
to his own army as he had a few moments
to decide a scene in which both Davos
Seaworth and tormund were hoping that
John will come back that he won't lead
his army to a certain defeat those few
scenes were perfect example of John's
personality and the way of thinking that
has changed after the betrayal of his
own people after his own death if this
battle somehow happens before his
resurrection we
she wouldn't be possible since if not
for his own death which led him to lead
the ancient order to leave the Nights
Watch as his watch ended he would have
still been on the wall but let's imagine
is that battle somehow did happen before
the season 5 finale the Battle of the
bastards would have been much different
first off a ponic of that john wouldn't
have charged would have led his army to
a certain defeat which he did because he
wanted to be in control over his own
destiny not because Ramsey played him
out but because of Jon's fear that he
doesn't have control over his own life
because some kind of God brought him
back to life for some purpose which John
doesn't understand and at the same time
is confused since there was nothing
after that
his last hope for his purpose and desire
for life disappeared with Wickham's life
at that point at a point in which he
went down at a point in which the enemy
cavalry was charging on him John was
ready to die he has done everything he
could but still fail to save his little
brother's life in his opinion he was
ready and assured that the moment in
which he gloriously pulled his sword out
that it's his final swing his final
fight and that's one of the two moments
in which John let's call it started
recovering over his resurrection that's
a moment in with John's army that he
somehow managed together showed up and
saved his life this moment in which John
was ready to die but at the same time
that's a moment in the John started
figuring out that he led his army to a
certain defeat that those men which
would have surely abandoned any other
general in order to save their own heads
by they didn't abandon John they charged
into the enemy they charged with
awareness of a certain defeat they
charged because they loved and believed
in John Snow as the battle progressed
John was almost buried the lie beneath
the bodies that situation in which
traumatised resurrected John would have
given up and died but not John who
realized that he is much more important
for his own people for the Nords more
than he thought
not John who literally experienced the
rebirth who decided to fight to fight
beside his people until his last breath
that's the moment in which John crushed
under the weight and chaos of attackers
both dead and alive decided to leave and
fought his way up through
man and finally breathe it again let me
just add that this whole scene in the
John almost died in a human crash was
actually kit harington's own idea which
director Miguel support Nick accepted
John's looking his eyes upon climbing
over the bodies and the stair that he
gave to Ramsey that's the moment to meet
John fully recovered of his death and
resurrection a moment in which John
decided to live to fight even if he is
going to die again eventually but he
will fight until his last day he will
make choices following his honor and his
inner voice as he always did he
Carrington said that his Saint scene is
some kind of a rebirth for him along
with the statement that John didn't stay
down upon being almost buried alive
because he decided to live he fought and
survived so yeah John's dead they bring
him fear and confusion which he fought
against the whole last season but
finally beated up in the moment of
retaking his home upon regaining
Winterfell
in conclusion John has changed mentally
he knows that there is only one life and
he will doubtlessly try to do as much as
he can will continue to fight for his
man for his people
additionally now that he is the king in
the north the king chosen by people the
king that will give his best to defend
the living side from the undead army
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one
you
[Music]